bienvenue à l'aéroport de chicago ici
les voyageurs revenant d'europe doit
faire preuve de patience
les citoyens américains est résident
permanent aux états unis se retrouvent
bloqués dans des files d'attentes
interminables parfois pendant plus de
sept heures en cause les nouveaux
contrôles dans le pays pour juguler la
propagation du coronavirus l'afflux de
passagers à dépister provoque la
pagaille dans les aéroports américains
et qui provoque aussi la colère des
autorités locales
lorsque le gouvernement fédéral n'écoute
pas et qu'ils n'enquêtent pas les
recommandations des maires et
responsables locaux
non seulement ça crée une tête non
seulement ça crée une catastrophe
les aussi une circonstance dangereuse
qui menace le public vous risquez de
provoquer des maladies graves et la mort
c'est une erreur et cela peut être évité
simplement en étant à l'étude au maroc
avec la suspension des vols vers la
france et d'autres pays européens
des milliers de touristes sont restés
bloqués principalement à marrakech
agadir ou encore tanger est pris en
otage
on est arrivé vendredi pour certains
d'autres enfin henri des avants on a eu
aucune consigne est en fait on ne peut
plus partir on est otage du maroc
parce qu'en fait
on nous a dit vous organisé avec notre
compagnie aérienne elle ne peut rien
nous proposer parce qu'il ya plus
d'avions finalement plusieurs avions
spéciaux sont partis ce dimanche et
maroc pour amener des milliers de
touristes européens
les images sont impressionnantes des
halls presque désert ça se passe à
munich
l'aéroport est pourtant l'un des plus
fréquentés d'europe le coronavirus
entraîne des annulations de vols en
cascade pour les compagnies aériennes du
monde entier
conséquence pour la compagnie
néerlandaise klm la suppression de 2000
emplois la réduction du temps de travail
de ses salariés et l'immobilisation de
ses boeing 747 à partir du 1er avril
de son côté la compagnie scandinave sas
prévoit de mettre jusqu'à 90 % de son
personnel au chômage technique dès lundi
seule bonne nouvelle peut être de
l'impact du corona virus sur l'économie
à l'industrie
les cartographies de la nasa qui
montrent une réduction drastique des
émissions de dioxyde d'azoté par les
usines chinoises aient de quoi rendre
l'air au dessus de la chine un peu plus
respirable
[Musique]